معارك في الخرطوم رغم سريان اتفاق الهدنه
الجديد والامم المتحده تحذر من تصاعد
للعنف وتسارع لوتيره اللجوء
روسيا تتهم مجموعه مسلحه تخريبيه اوكرانيه
بالهجوم على منطقه
بهدف تحويل الانتباه عن مخموط
ازمه سقف الدين في الولايات المتحده تزداد
تعقيدا بعد محادثات وصفت بالمثمره بين
بايدن والجمهوريين لكنها لم تنجح في
التوصل لاي اتفاق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره لاهم الانباء من
العربيه افاد شهود عن معارك في طواحي
الخرطومه الشماليه الشرقيه بعيده بدء
سريان اتفاق جديد لوقف اطلاق النار بين
طرفي النزاع المستمر منذ اسابيع وحذرت
الامم المتحده على لسان مبعوثها الى
السودان
فولكررت مما وصفته تحول صراع الذي يشهده
هذا البلد منذ اكثر من شهر الى نزاع ارقي
متنابي دعايه طرفي القتال الى التزام احدث
اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار اوبريم بينهما
وحضرت مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين من ان عدد السودانيين الذين
يلجاون الى تشاد هربا من المعارك يتزايد
بسرعه كبيره وقد بلغ حوالي 90 الف اللهجه
من جهه حضرت قوات الدعم السريع من ان
الزنجبيل القبليه والجهويه من قبل الجيش
ونظام السابق في صراع العسكري سيدخل
السودان في نفق حرب نهليه ستكلف الجيش
السوداني ما لا يستطيع رده وتحول الصراع
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه في الجنينه
في غربافور الى مواجهات بين القبائل
العربيه وقبيله البساليت مما ادى الى فرار
الالاف الى تشاد ومدن اخرى بالاقليم
نؤكد ان تمسك قوات الدعم السريع باستعاده
التحول الديمقراطي وانهاء الحلقه الشريره
التي دمرت السودان
الاندلابين يريدون تكرار تجربه الثلاثين
عام الماضيه نحن نديم قص المدنيين
والمستشفيات والمصانع وباقي البنيه
التحتيه بالطائرات والمدافع الثقيله
ونترحم على الارواح البريئه التي فقدناها
ندعو الشعب السوداني الى الانتباه الى
مخططات الفنون وحملات التضليل التي تهدف
الى توسيع دائره الحرب لن نتراجع الا بناء
هذا الانقلاب ومحاكمه كل من اجل في حق
الشعب السوداني والعوده الى المسار
الديمقراطي
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ضربت عده مناطق في المقاطعه
تحمل عبوات ناسفه اسفرت عن اختراق او
اختراق منزلين من دون وقوع عصابات في قريه
جراي بارون المتاخمه لاوكرانيا واعلن
اجلاد غوفن روسيا ادرجت المقاطعه ضمن
النظام القانوني لمنطقه عمليات مكافحه
الارهاب
وكان المتحدث باسم الكرم قد اعلن ان
مجموعه مسلحه تخريبيه دخلت منطقه
الحدوديه معتبرا ان الهجوم يهدف الى تحويل
الانتباه عن احتلال مخموت الذي تبنت موسكو
واضاف بسكوبا ووزاره الدفاع والجهاز الامن
الفيدرالي وحارس الحدود يتخذون كل تدابير
الضروريه للقضاء على هذه المجموعه
التخريبيه
في الاثناء تشير تقارير استخباراتيه الى
ان هناك تغييرات في الجيش الروسي ترقى الى
تشكيل قوات نخبه في سلاح الجو استعدادا
لمواجهه الهجوم المضاد الذي تخطط
بن
كهه الحيوانات هوموسكو في باخموت وان كان
الاعتماد فيه على قوات للسيطره على تلك
المدينه فقط فلا بد لها من اعاده ترتيب
صفوف القوات الروسيه الرسميه باختصار
القوات الروسيه تتغير
على مدى اشهر استنزفت روسيا قوات النخبه
التي عرفت باسم سبيتسناز على خطوط قتال
الاماميه تستعد عنها اليوم بقوات شتورم
وفق ما بينته وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
مجموعه طيران من طراز النخبه قد تشهد
مبارزه قاسيه مع مقاتلات اف 16 في سماء
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
كل وحده مدعمه بمقاتلات 24 و 34 تتولى
المناوره الجويه
وطائراتها تتولى مهام الهجوم الارضي
قدم حققته القوات الروسيه متوغله في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه طوال فتره الحرب
وقبلها في شبه جزيره القرم مكتسبات
ستحميها موسكو بكل السبل متركزه في نقاط
اساسيه معظمها جنوب اوكرانيا بحسب
خنادق وحواجزه وتحصينات رصدتها البي بي سي
من خلال صور الاقمار الصناعيه لتحدد تمركز
نقاط الدفاع والتكتيكات الدفاعيه
جنوب اقليم زابوريا حيثما تزال المعارك
محتدمه هو مفتاح لبوابه شبه جزيره القرم
ونقطه هدف للهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
مطار برديانسك بقرب بحر ازوق والذي يعتبر
قاعده رئيسيه للمقاتلات الروسيه
كل منسك شماليه شبه الجزيره والديان كوي
التي تضم قاعده جويه روسيه بوابات اساسيه
للقرم بالاضافه لحمايه الطريق اي 105
الواصل بين ميليتو بول التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا وخر كيف الاوكرانيه
رعب انتشر قبل الان بين الدول الاوروبيه
الاعضاء في حلف الناتو من توسع روسيا على
حدودها الرعب بات الان من التورط في حرب
كبرى فكيف للحلف ان يواجه جيشا في طور
التحول ويخرج من معارك قاسيه لتشدد مجله
نيوز على ضروره احداث تغييرات على قوه
الحلف لمواجهه خصمها في الشرق الى عمر
العربيه
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان دفعه جديده
قبل جوله الاعاده المقرره للانتخابات
الرئاسيه الثامن والعشرين من مايو الجاري
بكسب دعم المرشح الخاصر سنان اوغان لكنه
مراقبين يتساءلون ان كان الدعم الذي
تلقاهم مؤخرا سيكفيه لحسم الانتخابات
لمصلحته بنسبه كبيره
اخيرا حسم المرشح الخاسر في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه بجولتها الاولى سنان
اوغان قراره ودعم مرشح تحالف الشعب الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان
اطلبوا مناخبين الذين صوتوا لنا في الجوله
الاولى التصويت للسيد اردوغان في الجوله
الثانيه
اوغان دعم مجددا الى ترحيل اللاجئين
معتبرا ان مشكلتهم تمثل قضيه امن قوميا
للبلاد ايضا انتقد حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
الكردي وقال ان تحالف الامه المعارض لم
يقنعه موقف اوغان اشعل الجدل في التحالف
الذي يمثله وهو تحالف الاجداد فمنذ اعلان
نتائج الانتخابات البرلمانيه والرئاسيه
ظهر للعلن ان التحالف ليس على قلب رجل
واحد فيما يخص الجوله الثانيه حزب العداله
وهو حزب صغير داخل التحالف قرر مرشح تحالف
الامه كمال كالجدار اوغلو بينما اعلن
اوميت اوزداغ الذي يعرف بمواقفه التي توصف
بالعنصريه وهو رئيس حزب النصر الذي ينتمي
اليه اوغان اعلن ان قرار المرشح الرئاسي
بدعم اردوغان لا يعبر عن وجهه نظر الحزب
انما وجهه نظره الشخصيه لا يمكن ان يكون
هناك تصويت كامل من قبل كتله سنان اوغان
للرئيس اردوغان هذا موقف شخصي لسنان اوغان
وبالتالي تحالف الاجداد لا يمكن ان يذهب
كله للرئيس اردوغان لان ذلك سوف يتعارض مع
قيامهم ومباديهم التي اعلن عنها والتي دخل
مرشحهم منافسا لهم في الانتخابات وحصل
اوغام في الجوله الاولى على
5.7% من الاصوات لكن نصف هذه الاصوات جاءت
من حزبي النصر والعداله اللذين فشلا في
دخول البرلمان بينما كانت بقيه الاصوات من
الكتله القوميه في تحالف الطاوله السداسيه
الرافضين لترشيحك الجدار اوغلو فقررت دعمه
بعد انسحاب محرم انجي الذي صوت شطر من
انصاره ايضا لاوغان لا شك ان اردوغان كسب
في اعلان اوغان دعمه له ورغم تفتت تحالف
الاجداد يحتاج اردوغان نسبه مئويه بسيطه
تضمن له الفوز بعكس منافسه كالجدار اوغلو
الذي يحتاج كامل الكتله التصويتيه التي
صوتت لاوغان في الجوله الاولى وبراي
كثيرين بات اردوغان اقرب لحسم المعركه
الانتخابيه في الرئاسه بعد البرلمان لكن
نسبه التصويت تبقى عاملا اساسيا في يوم
الحسم زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
بعد ان اغلقت الاف المخابز ابوابها في
مناطق عده بتونس اثر عدم توافر المواد
الاساسيه لصناعه الخبز قال الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد ان الخبز خط احمر للمواطن ولن
يتم سكوته عما وصفه بمحاوله تجويع الشعب
الخبز ايضا والمواد الاساسيه بالنسبه الى
المواطن خط احمر
وهناك جمله
من الدوائر واللوبيات التي تسعى الى تاجيج
الوضع
واسمائهم معروفه
والتعلم بهذا الخبز المصنف وغير المصنف
الى اخر ذلك كله غير مقبول
الخبز المواطن بالفعل لابد ان يتوفر
وتتوفر المواد الاساسيه بطبيعه الحال
اليوم في وزاره الفلاحه وفي ديوان الحبوب
وعلى ديوان الحبوب ان يكون في مستوى
المرحله وعلى كل الادارات في تونس ان تكون
في مستوى المرحله لانه لا يمكن
ان نواصل التعامل مع هؤلاء
ونتركهم يعبثون بقوت المواطن ويعبثونه
بحياته في كل اوجهها في كل مستويات
وفي ليبيا ترى مقطع فيديو لرئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد بيبه الجدل
خلال زيارته لجناح تركيا في معرض ليبيا
للانشاءات في طرابلس حيث ظهرت بيبه سائلا
مدير الجناح اذا ما كان من مواليديه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان او لا
مؤكدا ان الذين صوتوا لصالح اردوغان هم
فقط من يمكنهم العمل في ليبيا وان عملهم
في البلاد مرتبط بتاييدهم للرئيس التركي
ان شاء الله اللي مثال
ان شاء الله
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
صوره مزيفه لانفجار في البنتاجون تتسبب
بتراجع البورصه الامريكيه بضعه دقائق
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن البيت الابيض عن
عدم توصل الرئيس جو بايدن ورئيس مجلس
النواب الاتفاق حول كيفيه رفع سقف دين
الحكومه الامريكيه
وضغط كيفن على البيت الابيض للموافقته على
تخفيض الانفاق في الميزانيه الاتحاديه
فيما دعى الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى
فضل الضرائب جديده على الاثريه وهو ما
يرفضه الجمهوريون
ابدى الرئيس الامريكي جوزيف بايدن حرصه
على التوصل الى اتفاق حول رفع سقف الدين
وهو كان يفتتح اجتماعا مع رئيس مجلس
النواب الجمهوري
نريد خفض العجز واضيف انني في سنتين خفضت
العجز الى تريليون و700 مليار دولار
واتطلع الى متابعه الامر
الحرصه ذاته لكنه مثل الرئيس بايدن اشار
الى ان مطالبه تتعدى سقف الدين الى خفض
المصروفات
اعتقد اننا متفقون على تغيير الاتجاه
ومعالجه الدين الضخم ونستطيع التوصل الى
قاسم مشترك نحو اقتصاد اقوى ونعالج الدين
والاهم ان نجعل الحكومه تواجه تضخم وتخفض
الاتكالها على الصين
المطالب المتبادله بين مكارثي وبايدن
اسبابها سياسيه فالرئيس الامريكي لا
يستطيع التخلي عن انجازات ادارته في شؤون
البيئه والطاقه
الناخبون الشباب يريدون تقدما في مجال
البيئه وهذا الامر الوحيد الذي انجزته
اداره بايدن ولو تم التخلي عنه سيكون
الامر كارثه للحزب الديمقراطي
اما رئيس مجلس النواب فيواجه ضغوطات كبيره
من نوابه الجمهوريين ويجازف بخساره منصبه
لو قدم تنازلات
لمكارسي هو يتوصل الى اتفاق ولكنه يخسر
تعيد اليمين في حزبه وياتي نائب ويطرح
الثقه به ويغفر منصبه
ولزياده الضغوطات اكدت وزيره الخزانه في
رساله وجهتها الى مكارثي ان بدايه شهر
يونيو هي الموعد المنتظر لتخلف الولايات
المتحده عن دفع المستحقات الماليه
وبالتالي لم تترك يلن فسحه لاطاله مهله
المفاوضات
مكارثي خرج بعد الاجتماع ليعلن للصحفيين
متابعه المفاوضات
اشعر اننا اجرينا نقاشا مثملا وليس لدينا
اتفاق بعد قرابه نصف الامريكيين يعتبر انه
يجب رفع سقف الدين ولكن اكثر من الثلث
يعترض على ذلك والسبب هو تضخم الدين
وضروره معالجه مصروفات الدوله وهذا يدعم
موقف الجمهوريه يرغنم العربيه
اعلنت السلطات الامريكيه القبض على سائق
شاحنه بعد اصطدامها بحواجز مبنيه في ميدان
لافيات سكوير قرب البيت الابيض وذكر رسول
الاتصال بجهاز الخدمه السريه ان حادثه
الصدام الشاحنه في الحواجز الامنيه لم
تسفر عن وقوع اصابات لاي من عناصر الامن
او موظفي البيت الابيض واضاف المسؤول
الامني ان الشرطه اغلقت بعض الطرق وممرات
المشعه
انتشرت على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ولفتره وجيزه صوره مزيفه لانفجار في
المنتوجون مما تسبب بتراجع البورصه لبضع
دقائق قبل ان تعود وتتعافى فورا نفي وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه صحه هذه الصوره ورجح عدد
من المراقبين ان تكون هذه الصوره نتيجه
للذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي وقد تنقلتها
حسابات عديده على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
من دون ان يتضح مصدرها الاصلي من مضطر
مونتاجون لاصدار نفي الرسمي لصحتها مؤكدا
عدم وقوع اي انفجار في محيط
رفعت شركه تيك توك المملوكه والتطبيق تيك
توك المبروك لشركه الصينيه دعوه قضائيه
لمنعه ولايه مونتانا من حظر التطبيق
الشهير مما ادى الى جهودها لوقف الحظر
الذي سيكون الاول منوعه في البلاد وفي
دعوه قضائيه مرفوعه امام محكمه مقاطعه
مونتانا قالت الشركه ان تشريعات مونتانه
تنتهك تعديل الاول واجزاء من دستور
الولايات المتحده مما يمثل تحديا لسلطات
الولايه اضافت الشركه في الدعوه ان الحضره
يغلق بشكل غير دستوري منتدى الكلام لجميع
المتحدثين على التطبيق
اكد وزير الدفاع السعوديه الامير خالد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز استمرار دعم المملكه
لمجلس القياده الرئاسيه اليمني في
المجالات كافه مما يختم الشعب اليمني
بالاضافه الى دعم جهود المبعوث الاومبي
لتوصل الى حل سياسي شامل في اليمن يحقق
السلامه والنماء جاء ذلك خلال استقبال
رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسيه اليابانيه
رشاد محمد العليمي في مقر اقامته خلال
زيارته للسعوديه الامير خالد بن سلمان وفق
ما افادت به وكاله الانباء السعوديه
وفي اليمن دخل مشروعه اعاده تاهيل مطار
عدد الدولي مرحلته الثالثه والاخيره حيث
يعمل البرنامج السعودي لاعاده اعمار اليمن
على اتمام الاشغال استعدادا لتدشير المطار
واعاده تشغيل هذه المنشاه الحيويه التي
تعرضت للتدمير من طرف الميليشيات الحوثيه
اعمال الصيانه وتاهيل مطار عدن الدولي في
مرحلتها الثالثه لا تتوقف بعد انجاز
المرحلتين الاولى والثانيه والتي خصصت
لتاهيل المدرج والمباني واماكن الشاحن
وساحه وقوف الطائرات ومنظومه التكييف
المركزي وتجهيز مستلزمات الامن والسلامه
والدفاع المدني الاحوال الاشقاء كلهم دور
ملموسه بعد التاهيل المطار على الدولي بعد
ما تعرض لكثير من التدمير والتخريب اثناء
حرب الحوثيه العالم في عام 2015
يعني تضمن الدعم على ثلاث مراحل للمرحله
الاولى تمثلت في اعاده تاهيل
والذي كان انتهى عمل الافتراضي قبل حوالي
اربع سنوات كان مغلق كذلك بعد ما تعرض
المطار للضربه
الجويه
اثناء استقبال حكومه النصر 30 ديسمبر يعني
قد دمرت صارت كبار الضيوف وجزء كبير من
صاله المغادره تم اعدتها بالكامل بحوالي
يمكن اثنين مليون دولار كذلك اعاده تاهيل
ساحه وقوف الطائرات
استعدوا البرنامج السعودي لتنشيد المرحله
الثالثه والتي ستخصص لتاهيل المدرج
الرئيسي
وتحديث انظمه الملاحه والجاهزيه التشغيليه
والنواحي التقنيه لتواكب المطارات الدوليه
بما يمكن مطار عدن من استقبال عدد اكبر من
الرحلات في المستقبل
المرحله الثالثه الذي سوف تحتوي
المدرج الهبوط والاغلاق الذي هو مبرر بشكل
كبير بالاضافه الى الاجهزه الملاحيه
الخطوط الالي وغيرها من الاجزاء الملاحيه
الذي تحصل الهبوط والاغلاء في مطار عدن
الدولي كعل هذا المطر وقد تعرض لتدمير
كامل على يد الميليشيات الحوثيه التي
سيطرت عليه لاربعه اشهر عام 2015
وبعد تحرير عدم تولى البرنامج السعودي
لاعاده اعمار اليمن مهمه اعاده تاهيل
المطار الذي يعد الشريان الرئيسي الذي
يربط اليمن بباقي دول العالم ياتي مشروع
اعاده تاهيل مطار عدن الدولي ضمن 229
مشروع مبادره تنمويه نفذها البرنامج
السعودي لتنميه اعمار اليمن في شتى
المحافظات اليمنيه طبعا المشروع اعاده
تاهيل مطار عدن الدولي تم الانتهاء ولله
الحمد من المرحله الاولى والثانيه
وسيتم الاستئناف ان شاء الله او بدل
الاستئناف في المرحله الثالثه والاخيره
والتي تضمن اعاده تاهيل المدرج الرئيسي
بالاضافه الى
توفير
وتركيب الاجهزه الملاحيه
لواكب مطار عدن الدولي ان شاء الله
المطارات العالميه
كان تاهيل مطار عدن الدولي واحده من
اولويات البرنامج السعودي اعمار اليمن
المطار اهميه لعدن وباقي المحافظات
اليمنيه حيث ان هذا المطار هو الشريان
الرئيس الذي يربط البلاد بالعالم الخارجي
ردفان دبيس العربيه عدد
وفي ختام هذه النشره تذكير بابرز ما جاء
فيها من اخبار
معارك في الخرطوم رغم سريان اتفاق الهدنه
الجديد والامم المتحده تحذر من تصاعد
للعنف وتسارع لوتيره الهجوم
روسيه تتهم مجموعه مسمحه تخريبيه اوكرانيه
بالهجوم على منطقه
بهدف تحويل الانتباه عن محمود وكيف تنفي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات